[Music]
what's up my babies it's episode 176 of
congratulations it's officially [ __ ]
lit dude so I was I was sick a little
bit on this it's Thursday I don't think
I've ever record a podcast on Thursday
night because I always said I would do
it Monday and if I couldn't do it Monday
I said I'd do it Tuesday and if contused
a I said I always do a Wednesday and I
never thought I'd have to be like if I
couldn't do a Wednesday I'll do a
Thursday but lo and behold [ __ ] a
little bit shitty Wednesday felt even
more shitty or Tuesday felt kind of the
same shitty on Wednesday and then
Thursday your boys on the mend yes
so I also was nerve nervous because of
the whole Kovich [ __ ] that was going on
so I went to get tested by coke bike the
covert police and [ __ ] don't have it
dude got tested twice yes got the same
doctor to come by that [ __ ] went by
Joe Rogan's to do it podcast buddies did
it and he came by [ __ ] tested my
whole family nobody's got it [ __ ] yeah
dude nobody's got co-ed but you know I
mean nobody that well some people have
COBIT kovat but anyway I hope you guys
are doing okay and I hope you're not
contracting kovat but if you did I hope
you guys are getting better like [ __ ]
what is it two million people in the USA
have it now so that's I love how Trump's
was trying to act like it's gone we're
better we're better folks and then it's
just literally another million people
just [ __ ] coughing it up dude I want
to start off this podcast with a bang
dude with a straight-up bang all right I
just saw this video of this lady
approaching this man and he's and and I
parent I think he's in a car I haven't
seen this whole video yet but this girl
goes from [ __ ] Mach 4 I'd say to Mach
11 immediately okay I mean it's the the
the she takes it so she goes so hard in
the paint she goes from chillin like
ready
do you know doing the Conor McGregor arm
arm swinging thing just like okay I'm
ready I'm ready
you know I know this is silly but and I
know that's a fight but I know it's
silly but it's all gonna be just being
silly right now to just a [ __ ] rear
naked choke Mach 11 I'm just gonna play
it until she goes to Mach 11 and I'm
telling you right now this is the first
[ __ ] pre-emptive you're ever gonna
get so I'm just gonna say ah to get it
out of the way and then you'll know when
it happens that's how [ __ ] hardcore
this is okay I cannot [ __ ] believe
this you play games we don't play games
I play games where you get [ __ ] to
death I conduct myself oh just a [ __ ]
looks like a nice sweet lady that would
like give you pie but instead say I play
games where you can go get [ __ ] to
death laughs dude oh I mean my god dude
dude is she from is this a joke or she
from Torrance
dude this is unbelievable I guess
another saying she's a Karen she's Karen
but she's not Karen oh my god I Rex
Chapman tweeted this so that's where you
can find that
but Jesus Christ dude it already has 1.2
million I mean the the [ __ ] tsunami
that could look what she's wearing dude
Wow
every single thing she has on is worse
than the other thing it's unbelievable
she has a [ __ ] I hate fisherman's
hats do it even if I was fishing if I
was a fisherman I would never wear a
fishing hat
they look so [ __ ] like janky and
lopsided he and [ __ ] and then a thing
over her neck for her kovat protection
obviously but not using it and then a I
don't even know what a muumuu is I never
knew what a muumuu was but she's wearing
that probably and then [ __ ] a blue
camouflage shorts camos green or tan or
gray if you're in the you know a James
Bond movie and the [ __ ] ice but dude
blue well she could be swimming well
they are bait it is a bathing suit I
play a game where you can get [ __ ] to
death
never I mean just just [ __ ] to death
I'm gonna keep I'm gonna play I haven't
heard the rest of this games where you
get [ __ ] I did not one game there's
multiple games and she plays those games
I play games where you get [ __ ] to
death dude if she said that to me in my
car window I would immediately go like
this sign me up
and I would hold that note until she did
something that's absolutely [ __ ]
amazing Wow
you know what the thing is if you're
gonna be racist go all the way don't be
the person like you know what I'm
talking you know what she is she's
[ __ ] hardcore old school traveling on
a boat racist you know what I'm talking
about
like we're you let you you like like
back in the [ __ ] 14 know the 1700s
we're like you know now it's about
microaggressions and [ __ ] and people are
like did you just are you did you just
does that mean what if that's that's the
most of the racism that you see in
pockets of the world now besides
obviously I know the [ __ ] real hard
truth but like the the usually you and
your buddies notice this [ __ ] where
you're like did that person just is that
what the person did this person mean
that she can't but the Dom talking now
there's those kinds of racist moments I
get it I know that there's harder racist
moments but just [ __ ] live in this
comedy bit for a little bit alright but
this lady is like hello hey [ __ ] all
that subtle [ __ ] she's doing this [ __ ]
that guy's did in the 1700s where it was
just like if you the white dudes thought
if you weren't racist you were you were
the dumb one you know you just be out at
sea and be like well we won't allow
blacks on the boat and and everyone and
just keep sailing that's the hurt I well
we can play games and the kind of games
we play well you get some [ __ ] pasty
white fat [ __ ] that's gonna die at 42
Pat in his [ __ ] forehead with a with
a hankie you know that up that dude
Amen that guy those guys were real guys
those guys [ __ ] sucked
just wearing all tan always all tan no
zero colors oh my it's such a hot day
isn't it you bro you're wearing so much
clothes by the day's the day is long the
days as long as the blazing arms you
know the days of so many [ __ ]
analogies and what do you call them
metaphors the nicest laws is a nice day
Blazers you can get [ __ ] to death
this is the day is long that's the
racist she is dude okay I want to watch
the rest of it though wow I haven't seen
this yet oh dude my if you don't know
this already my favorite [ __ ] thing
is when someone is so rip-roarin mad in
their heart when they can't help
themselves and they're so rip-roarin mad
in their heart and their default is
being as nice as they possibly can
because there's levels of mad you know
there's the kind of matter like your
friend pinches you and it's too hard and
he didn't know how hard it was and
you're like are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't do that [ __ ] and then there's the
level of wow that [ __ ] crossed
me I'm gonna go yell at that
[ __ ]
but then there's the kind of mad where
you can't believe what the [ __ ] is
happening and you're just like okay well
let me hold the door open for you yeah I
know life's great for you isn't it
there's that everyone just holds the
door open for you done it that's how mad
she is only she's in the wrong probably
I don't know the beginning of the video
but it sounds like she's being racist
but she's being so nice dude but besides
the thing she's saying her demeanor I
mean
jörg she says you're going to go to real
jail now what doesn't need to say the
word real also I think oh god some races
there hold on
I think you're going oh so racist Wow
blows my mind three times she says you
understand me [ __ ] unbelievable dude
this is a minute into the video she's
like [ __ ] it it's all over Facebook I
don't care park the car and she's parked
like an [ __ ]
she says this is from my government you
go home and you get [ __ ] so not from
the government also I don't know maybe
Trump would actually tweet that you know
and people will be like well well
yeah what a what a piece of [ __ ] this
lady did you finish college
did you finish college did you know did
you nothing right there this woman is in
her 50s or 60s here's the worst part
about it she's not even doing a good job
of roasting the guy if you're gonna be
[ __ ] like what a supreme [ __ ]
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] dude
imagine you were married to someone and
they just did that I mean you'd have to
divorce them your life would be a
[ __ ] living hell
first of all she's she provided an I
guess she didn't have a job my thought
if you do that you're gonna get fired
that's it
that's it you're gonna get fired because
you can't
I don't even it's it even though I know
people are racist like that it's so hard
for me to understand that people
actually think like that and would talk
like that like there's a level of [ __ ]
that happens sometimes or it's like I
know it's true but I still don't feel
that it's true because I don't operate
that way I mean this woman isn't 60
maybe and she's going China man like to
the guy on [ __ ] real this piece of
[ __ ] this is the [ __ ] that the the the
the bad Trump made this woman feel like
she was right you know
Wow Wow it's
so hard not to be political by the way I
try harder and harder each episode I
don't even know what this lady is doing
is obviously piece of [ __ ]
whether you're if you're if you think
what that lady's doing is not a piece of
[ __ ]
III you're not a real person to me
that's unbelievable so let's just not
this is not about politics I know I said
Trump once or twice in there but Jesus
Christ man that is just that is just
insane are you mental for being that way
uh I I saw how oh man Trump's thing with
the Bible was [ __ ] hysterical I mean
did you really hold the bottle upside
down I have no [ __ ] idea I know
people were saying that but that's
something that [ __ ] left the leftists
would say and be like you know you
[ __ ] a ho you [ __ ] hold it upside
down - and they're like latch onto the
wrong thing to be mad about
which is what they [ __ ] which what the
left always does walking his tweets dude
all right you know all right
the things that the left latches on to
and says are the problems are not the
problem the thing that CNN reports about
that are the problems are usually not
the [ __ ] actual problems and then it
makes the right be like they're [ __ ]
idiots they're complain about the dumb
[ __ ] and then the right gets stronger
and left I don't want to [ __ ] talk
about I say I'm not political I don't
want to talk about this but anyway Trump
did the [ __ ] Bible thing and went to
go take the picture and do it he did it
I'm I think I saw this online somewhere
before somebody was like he he went out
from the White House to take this photo
in the midst of protesters the day after
he was in the bunker and people were
roasting him on Twitter about being in
the bunker and you know that the reason
that he did that was because everyone
was roasting him about being in the
bunker
so he was like I'll show him and went
and walked into the midst of the
protestors with the cops tear gassing
everybody to take the picture in front
of the church to show that he's not
scared that is just how humans work if
you're acting like a baby now the best
the funniest [ __ ] thing to me was
like the symbolism of him wanting to
build a wall and the fact that he got to
but it was around the White House so
nobody would [ __ ] drag him out is
unbelievable dude like he wanted to
build a wall that was what he ran on a
lot of people thought it was ridiculous
and then he got to build a wall just
with so many more or less cubic [ __ ]
feet in it just imagine just a little
fence around him just like this finally
built my wall dude that's so [ __ ]
funny that's would make me feel like
such a [ __ ] dude anyway so I guess the
other option is voting for Biden whoo
man ah you know this whole world is just
so [ __ ]
I mean Biden can't remember what he is
saying at the moment so that's your your
memory yeah yeah are you ever like what
did I eat for lunch he is forgetting
[ __ ] that he didn't even say yet you
know I'm talking about so that's all so
[ __ ] horrible
I just need [ __ ] I don't know who
could be a president I have [ __ ] no
idea dude let's get off
this [ __ ] political [ __ ] but I saw
this couple on The Bachelor
I don't watch The Bachelor I got hooked
in a roped into watching it I don't
watch that show because why the [ __ ]
would I ever watch people competing for
love like you don't compete for love
ever
I've never what unless you're 12 or 15
and you're trying to compete with
another 14 15 year-old like once I grew
up if I'm ever going for a girl if I was
ever going for a girl and my buddy was
like bro I'm going for that girl I go
like this this is always what I've been
go ahead go ahead
what the [ __ ] do I care have a fun time
do the horizontal mambo with her marry
her
take care I don't give a [ __ ] I'm not
gonna try and I'm not getting in front
of friend or not even friend or not if I
was at a [ __ ] bar or a club which I
don't normally go to but if I was and
another guy was into a girl and I knew
and I didn't know the guy and I thought
the girl was hot and then he's hitting
on her I go ari I'm not I don't I'm not
on this [ __ ] she likes me or she likes
you
I'm not involved with this [ __ ]
though so I don't even care when there's
not cameras on it putting cameras on
some [ __ ] that I don't give a [ __ ] about
makes me even more not give a [ __ ] about
it because then you're sitting down to
watch it and ready to [ __ ] you know
it's all event so the bachelor to me
blows [ __ ] donkey dicks okay I would
never watch it now reality TV is a weird
[ __ ] thing because literally like
only girls like it and gay guys but like
no dude and ironic or not dude I don't
when some guys get together like you you
have a bachelor bachelorette night and
it's funny bro you're boring in your
dorky dude get a real personality
don't pretend you like the Bachelorette
and watch it you know so so
I got roped into watching this and you
know my girls like oh you got a you know
just watch it and I it was like a
[ __ ] two-hour reek it was like a it's
like a thing on I don't know Hulu or
some [ __ ] it's like a two hour of quick
version of the season and catching up
where they are now and [ __ ]
so I'll wash it a little bit of it and I
saw this couple Sean Lowe and Catherine
Lowe okay and they're so goddamn
actually adorable that it's made me be
like well what the goddamn [ __ ] man
because they're so like she's so cute
and so sweet and he is so exactly the
kind of guy that I would want to like be
around and hang it hang out with I mean
there's one weird thing about him was I
think he was like saving he was like a
born-again virgin because he wanted to
save himself from marriage to two he
didn't want to have sex with the person
until they married because you used to
be a player or something and then he
like gave up that lifestyle cuz he
thought I'd never get a I'll never get a
girl if I keep living this way which is
crazy I always think that's crazy when
guys say that like you know I'm gonna do
matter so you put a blue sex on the back
burner but true like a real person and
then dude then you lead yourself into a
place where you're like oh I really like
this chick I think I really like to
check and then you have sex with her and
then god forbid it's like you're having
sex with [ __ ] dry toast and you're an
even worse sometimes she's not an even
the problem you're the problem with her
you're like oh [ __ ] I'm the problem here
I don't know how to [ __ ] do it with
her and then you love the girl but the
sex is bad and you're like you know what
I think I still make it worth work you
get down on one knee and then after that
you have kids and then it sucks and the
[ __ ] is all like you know ho-hum because
the sex was never that good I thought
that sex wasn't the most important thing
in a relationship and it's so one of the
most important things in a relationship
man and guess what dude
your boy bangs it out and I've got my
own moves I don't do it like how they do
it how they show it on TV and [ __ ]
I saw one [ __ ] show the other day a
movie the other day huh it was it's
called an ax it's with that guy who's in
all those British movies and this girl
who used to be a model and now she's an
actress who's so hot by the way
Sasha loose and they [ __ ] each other
and it's like what are they doing
dude she clears the table and then he
throws her on the table with her clothes
on and then her clothes were still on so
he like takes her off the table and he
rips our clothes off and it's like relax
dude you'll get there
dude part of [ __ ] is before the
[ __ ] part of the fun of [ __ ] is
before the [ __ ] dude everything
before the thing that actually happens
is more fun than the thing that actually
happens that's it do it put that on my
tombstone everything that happens is not
as fun as before it happens you've been
to a bangin party yeah what was more
exciting than that driving on the way to
the party man what's gonna happen all in
your head man is gonna be checks dude
how many 12 probably really yep hot ones
12 hot ones and they're gonna be all
single 11 of them are get the [ __ ] out
really and you get there and there's
[ __ ] two hot chicks and one has to
leave early and the other one hooks up
with [ __ ] who's the guy from Nick
Stahl the Terminator guy cuz he's at the
party - the guy who everyone pretended
was missing for [ __ ] five years and
then he was he was just like yeah he's
just taking it is you know and and so so
anyway I watched this [ __ ] bachelor
thing and anyway he did the and and
they're just so [ __ ] cute and funny
dude and I saw the guy's Instagram Sean
Lowe Pro the guy says the funniest [ __ ]
about his kids he had his third daughter
he had his third kid which is a daughter
and he was like everyone every every
parent says there's something like every
parent says they don't I don't have the
faith they they pretends like they don't
have their favorite kid or whatever
and I'm so proud to say that I finally
have mine and he's holding his daughter
like that's hilarious
I love that couple men so I don't
so listen [ __ ] the bachelor and the
Bachelorette I don't even know which one
it was that would they were on but that
that couple I'm with them till the end
dude I'll ride with them till the wheels
fall off and that's the thing too that's
life
I was like on this [ __ ] the bachelor
[ __ ] the Bachelorette [ __ ] and I saw
that and I don't have an open mind dude
my mind is closed shut man you know how
my mind is narrow my mind's like a tight
[ __ ] dude but I saw it I was in a
certain mood and I felt a certain way
about it and now life is about change
life is about growth but guess what
after that it's like that [ __ ] thing
the it can cheat congeals like when an
alien gets shot and then it my mind's
back closed as [ __ ] after I saw that
those little [ __ ] that couple
Sean and Catherine Lowe and then I saw
that oh the [ __ ] terminator where
he's like bong bong-bong-bong and
there's a big like crescent-shaped hole
and his arms hanging off and then it
[ __ ] congeals back and they starts
walking forward again I'm back to narrow
my tight [ __ ] mind and we look them up
they're cute dude and it's all about
being cute um okay so also I'm gonna do
ads but also it was very cool how [ __ ]
one fire said do you want me to add some
stuff on the notes for you six days ago
and I said sure why not
didn't add one thing cool one fire um
man that's what's up I was in I was in I
told you like this new clothing line
represent I wore that shirt last week
and then I got the I bought these other
shirts and I'm wearing it right now
I think I'm between a large and a
[ __ ] extra-large and that's where I
always am
I mean this kind of fits this is not an
ad by the way that's good it fits I
think I'm a large anyway the guy emailed
me because I talked about on the podcast
he was like I were gonna send you some
shirt so I said okay and then I said you
own my address he never wrote me back so
how the [ __ ] knows but whatever who
cares I like the shirts I don't go bad
on people just because they don't even a
back some people go bad on people when
they don't email back or don't text back
although if you're real good friends
with someone and then they don't do that
[ __ ] that's weird like Adam Devine did
that [ __ ] to me bro [ __ ] text me back
um uh anyway yeah there's some juicy hot
gossip for you yeah dude
[ __ ] would hit me back
constantly and now I guess [ __ ] he's
got that jacksie money but so what else
oh dude the [ __ ] look at this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] that I write in my notes that I
later have no idea what it means like
zero idea what this could possibly mean
the hierarchy of guys and [ __ ] worst
novel of all time the hierarchy of God
but one of the [ __ ] like a Dianetics
with that font and [ __ ] with a volcano
on it and if you look closely it's a
enough it's a it's a penis [ __ ]
coming so crass um dude I saw Joker
finally I saw Joker finally and it is so
[ __ ] good and I know everybody thinks
that and everyone says that but Jesus
Christ man here's what I think I could
do that I could be that guy and I can
have the [ __ ]
uprising that that character has and I
think honestly it starts with this
[ __ ] podcast and thank you
beforehand because I know these
[ __ ] the babies dude
these [ __ ] would listen you you
you listen right now in your [ __ ] car
or probably at home because it's sad and
you can't go anywhere unless you're in
Missouri but you you're my baby man and
if I ever get in a [ __ ] insane asylum
you come and you break me out man
because I need you dude I'm not staying
in that [ __ ] because what I'm
doing it's all I'm not evil okay Oh what
I think is that's what they did about
that movie that was so good they made
you feel for that dude and he was a
psychopath killer but the whole world is
different for me now that I have my son
man I watch everything different before
I had my son when I saw Joker I'd be
like had this [ __ ] guy Wow that's
badass that's crazy now that I have my
son
I see everyone as somebody's [ __ ] kid
and I get sad dude I watched Joker and I
got sad because I'm like man this
[ __ ] especially cuz he had to part
with his mom in it and I'm like I just
kid he was just a boy at one point you
know I want to say everyone should have
kids because it [ __ ] it changes your
[ __ ] world and I hate when people say
that but it's so true man
everyone was somebody's [ __ ] kid once
even the Joker even the Joker even the
real Joker but yeah god Joaquin Phoenix
was so good the whole movie so good Todd
Phillips I don't even understand how you
it's so hard to make a movie that's so
sound and wrapped up in its own world
and everything makes sense in that world
that's created and when it's
quote-unquote a real movie like a movie
that tries to be real I think it's in a
way even harder like take the matrix-12
me a great example of the movie that is
that creates a world and then adheres to
all the rules in its world and there's
no like false moments I mean maybe
there's one or two I don't know how to
see it again but
it makes sense within itself you know
people argue that like Star Wars is like
that I don't really watch Star Wars but
like you know it's like a philosophy and
it's hard to do that in a sci-fi movie
obviously but it's also in a way easier
because you could just make [ __ ] up
you know that's why I don't like a lot
of sci-fi movies because they'll be like
[ __ ] the world's inning and the leg yeah
well we and they just invented this
thing like oh really yeah
oh let's use it well the thing is it's
only on [ __ ] Mars oh well let's go to
Mars
well the only way we can get there now
because the fucking's ORS and nots
exploded the [ __ ] things where we got
to go back in time ah [ __ ] how do we do
that well there's the thing there's a
device okay I didn't know that yeah well
they just made it when in the future
what oh I just came back to tell you
this oh okay so you're not born yet now
and then if people are like did you
[ __ ] you know dorks with Black
Sabbath shirts or just eating popcorn
like well I mean this is [ __ ] amazing
and so but the joke to do it in a real
movie is is in a way harder because
people are expecting realness it's like
when people talk about the Chris no
Christopher Nolan Batman about the Joker
and how it was real like okay yeah it
did kind of adopt a realness to it but
dude at the end Batman was still [ __ ]
flying around from building the building
and like had technology that didn't
exist but the Joker Joker rather didn't
do that it was all stuff that could
possibly happen and the world that they
created in that world was all truthful
and it was just [ __ ] an amazing movie
man and Todd Phillips came to see me do
stand-up like a few weeks before Joker
came out and I was like I can't wait to
see a movie and I finally saw it and I
don't know if he [ __ ] will hear this
but dude I I mean I'm talking about I
can't stop thinking of that movie I
can't stop thinking about that movie and
how good it was
and here's what I think too
should've won Best Picture I didn't see
all the things but I saw a parrot a
parasite and that movie was good
it moves very good it I think best
screenplay okay
give it to parasite fine but that movie
was great but Joker was great and also
entertaining
I thought parasite was a little bit and
you know this could I'm sure this was
intentional it was a little bit harder
to watch because but but just every
moment a joker was just like and it was
it was it got away with being relevant
socially and also entertaining which is
like so [ __ ] hard anyway whatever
enough of that
since we're talking about movies let's
talk about [ __ ] James Bond I watched
this video the other day
oh my [ __ ] dude this killed me do it
there's a video on YouTube called seven
inappropriate moments James Bond
wouldn't get away with now and it's on
it's the pages Digital Spy and they just
go through seven moments that it
wouldn't know they're like some of them
with Sean Connery and the other guys and
[ __ ] but dude I just love it how times
change turns a woman around says man
talk and then slaps her ass and she
walks away they would imagine if Daniel
Craig did that in [ __ ] quantum leap
or whatever the [ __ ] it is condom
soulless for [ __ ] sake dude why do
they name [ __ ] movies something that
you would never know what it is I don't
know what quantum is I don't even barely
know what solace is put them shits
together or a ghost Protocol dude you
know go [ __ ] yourself
ghost Protocol yeah alright dude just
call the movie jumping around Tom Hanks
Tom [ __ ] cruise whatever did all his
old ran off a bit that's so dude Tom
Cruise is such a [ __ ] big
good successful actor that he's like no
and stuntman dude I've done it all I've
[ __ ] every kind of thing in the world
and I've made all the money tie me up
I'm swinging through that building so
here's the other one Jesus so loud
here's another one when he tells he does
the look what he tells the black guy oh
what turns to the black guy and says
fetch my shoes so racist here's another
one oh this [ __ ] the Indian with a bunch
of a bunch of Indian guys keep you in
curry for a few weeks I don't even
really know honestly what that means if
there's a few worries like slapping
women which is just crazy to me this is
the best one though I thought as in
worst one in an illogical and offensive
plan James attempts to blend in with the
locals in Japan by becoming Japanese
thanks to a bad wig fake tan eyebrow
extensions and some false ID lids dude
what is this [ __ ] Austin Powers I
didn't realize how
[Music]
and then he walks in he meets you and he
says like who walks into the undercover
to the lady and he says
Bombo ah and he doesn't even really look
more Japanese like there's another one
where he uses [ __ ] he doesn't take no
for an answer and where's another one
there was another good one I thought no
no that one this just makes me
uncomfortable tries to rape a lesbian
okay oh this was the one where he
[ __ ] puts the dwarf in a suitcase
Oh disconnected were he puts the dwarf
in a suitcase dude like he's fighting is
that even the right thing to say dwarf
it does what do you do vo says in a
fistfight with a dwarf
James ridiculously traps Knick Knack in
I mean the fact that he's called Knick
Knack anyway you know before carrying
him out of the room and he's fighting he
like he's just like walking towards him
with the suitcase and then just [ __ ]
and they caught they cut it to him
already in the suitcase obviously
because it would be [ __ ] impossible I
mean the [ __ ] guy's name is nick nack
prejudice Wow
you know imagine if you tried to get a
[ __ ] movie done and you had a dwarf
in it and his name was Nick knack in it
now wow-wow cancelled for me canceling
me for even supposing that I would love
if Daniel could say I want that [ __ ]
that everyone's trying to make the most
PC like now they're talking about how
the double of sevens gonna be a woman
and how James Bond has a daughter or
whatever the [ __ ] it is [ __ ] all that
dude go extra hard extra hard and just
be like the racist Bond
to where he's just like literally says
the n-word in Oh or like just says stuff
like well that's because they're stupid
about like just any other race what the
[ __ ] I the world would be over if if
James Bond came out I'll tell you what
though no matter what they do there's
gonna be a problem so I can't wait for
that I can't wait for the new James Bond
movie to come out with the with the
black female double-oh-seven or whatever
the hell it is I can't wait for that to
come out and I can't wait for the
problem mark my words
let me know that's me doing the Minority
Report [ __ ] for the movie review god
Terry Crews is the king of putting his
foot in his mouth huh
how he said the thing about the how he
said the thing about black supremacy
like I even understand what he was
trying to say and like I get that's the
[ __ ] weird thing is like honestly
what Terry Crews said was stupid but I
bet he's a [ __ ] good guy and I mean
maybe he's not what the [ __ ] do I know
but we get [ __ ] so hell-bent on what
people say that we don't know who they
that we don't consider who they actually
are and that's one of the biggest
problems I think you know like the Jimmy
Fallon thing dude you really think that
[ __ ] is a piece of [ __ ] because
he did the blackface in 2001 you really
think Jimmy Fallon doesn't deserve
everything he got because because of
that I know Jimmy Fallon I mean I've met
him I don't know twice the guy's the
nicest [ __ ] now apparently I
don't know I'm really well I mean
obviously I don't know him really well
not apparently I don't know Malheur well
but like these [ __ ] Terry Crews
what he said about the about
what'd he say about the [ __ ] Terry
Crews black supremacy let me google it
stands his ground Wow he stands his
ground I got to read this Terry Crews
this is on news-miner comm Terry Crews
found himself urging against groupthink
Monday defeating white supremacy Oh God
this is annoying his [ __ ] to get the
full story select an option below email
password bro [ __ ] you I'm not signing up
for news dude news is news you're lucky
I'm not on Twitter oh you only go to
Twitter I'll [ __ ] go to Twitter
stupid [ __ ] pay for news and [ __ ] here
we go LA Times does this work
Terry Crews
himself yeah here here it's free here
pay for [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you news
it's news defeating white supremacy
without white people creates black
supremacy equality is the truth like it
or not we're all in this together people
[ __ ] a lit him up for this obviously
it's obviously a dumb way to say this
okay but you know what the [ __ ] he's
saying for people to just be like
alright this [ __ ] [ __ ] him
forever it's just so weird to me it's
just so weird to me that whole cancel
cultures thing he took this time to
respond to a few people Godfrey said
Godfrey comedian I love you as a friend
brother Terry but I disagree with you
hundred percent no such thing as black
supremacy right well no [ __ ] there's
definitely such thing as black supremacy
that is a tactic that racist white used
I've actually never even heard the term
before until he said it but to
counteract our rebellion to their
horrific treatment of us it's called
gaslighting black pride is an ant
anti-white yeah agree Ted Cruz says I
agree I'm not discussing white people
here there are gatekeepers of blackness
with our own community who decide who's
black and who's not I have often been
called out for not being black enough
how can that be Kevin Powell responds
Terry with all due respect given your
platform you cannot just post something
like that even remotely suggest that
black people would fall into black
supremacy this is what I agree with that
for sure if we battle white supremacy
without white people yeah I agree with
that I think he just [ __ ] he's just a
he puts his foot in his [ __ ] mouth on
Twitter all the time Kevin I've learned
that people in this book Terry says
Kevin I've learned that people will take
anything you say and twist it for their
own evil anything I mean yeah I agree
with that too yeah see there's the other
thing Terry Crews please he tweet says
please know that everything I've said
comes from a spirit of love and
reconciliation for the black community
first
then the world as a whole in hopes to
see a better future for black people
like I believe that he thinks that so
that should be it you know we should
just [ __ ] in everyone's trying to do
there well no not everyone but a guy
like I believe that guy a guy like Terry
Crews is trying to do his best and
that's very important
so anyway anyway how he [ __ ] how
ripped is Terry Crews by the way is that
guy in his 50s no he's like 40 something
50 some he could be ninety who knows why
people good at they look good as [ __ ]
when they're older um I don't want to oh
yeah this is the thing I wanted to
[ __ ] find and talk about the [ __ ]
Kevin Spacey thing I kept though I never
talked about this Kevin Spacey
when he did they let me be frank video
this is some ride-or-die shed like this
is Ryder die shed and I would never God
what he did is bad trying to [ __ ] like
15 year old boys or whatever I should
don't know specifically what what he did
I know there was that kid who was in the
Star Trek series that he tried to [ __ ]
when he was like 16 I think that was
specifically all I know but man the fact
that Kevin Spacey let it go for like a
year and and he wrote and he did this
video where he was acting like the guy
from house of cards in his own video on
YouTube is just [ __ ] so ride-or-die
that I can't even believe it
he's washing his hands I was for
Christmas Eve he posts this I know what
you want yeah oh sure they may have
tried to separate us but what we have is
too strong is too powerful I mean after
all we shared everything you and I I
told you my deepest darkest secrets I
showed you exactly what people are
capable of okay he's in his [ __ ]
Frank [ __ ] as house of cards and it's
like he's is he gonna I'm like is he
gonna confess or what the [ __ ] but he's
playing this character puts this out
I've actually never watched his over I
shocked you with my honesty but mostly I
challenged you and made you think and
you trusted me even though you knew you
shouldn't so we're not done no matter
what anyone says yeah the worst [ __ ]
like background music or background
talking hey the camera shaking a little
bit I don't know what's going on dawg
the the background partygoers is so bad
that it sounds so fake listen listen to
it even though you knew you shouldn't so
we're not done no matter what anyone
says and besides I know what you want
you want me back a man confessed course
some believed everything and I've just
been waiting with bated breath to him he
confess at all I knew the words bated
breath was gonna be in this by the way
it's so Kevin Spacey to say bated breath
it's dying to have me declare that
everything said is true and that I got
what I deserved
wouldn't that be easy it was all so
simple
only you and I both know it's never that
simple it's so weird how actors are so
annoying when they're acting but then
also there's like Joaquin Phoenix when
he does the Joker and you're like oh
wait this is actually [ __ ] the [ __ ] I
don't understand the difference
sometimes like this is so bad to me it's
so [ __ ] weird politics and not alive
but you wouldn't believe the worst
without evidence would you you wouldn't
rush to judgment without facts yeah I
mean he's talking about himself as Frank
did you under what is it
a cigar not you you're smarter than that
anyway all this presumption made for
such a nun of course they're gonna say
I'm being disrespectful not playing by
the rules who wrote this is what I want
to know dude also I didn't realize
forgot about the conspiracy where people
think that he's murdering his accusers
somebody right who's hereafter wondering
if Kevin Spacey's murdering people what
did they say here or the peeps he knows
doing it for him they're all beyond a
joke at this point see this is the stuff
I just can't the conspiracy theory [ __ ]
is just so wild to me I know I've talked
about this before but like you think
Kevin Spacey is hiring people to kill
his accusers dude he would be caught
okay everyone's eyes are on him right
now right now only Italians are on our
eyes honor him and because they're there
and they don't give a [ __ ] about the me
to movement they're like oh what do you
mean the lady they don't want it no
ladies ever wanted you still they hate
when you call them in the street just
like from when you [ __ ] it doesn't you
have to force you know otherwise it
doesn't work
we're so gross you know they walk it on
the street you say hey chubby and at
your bail and they go ah ah and they try
to run away but you chase you you chase
you grab you know me too me too I grab
you um they don't give a [ __ ] you you
you [ __ ] and they end up liking you
Wow and then you eat the spaghetti
together and then I you know if they
don't like it the spaghetti you make
them eat all of it until they like it
eat it that's what the whole Italian
culture is dude my whole [ __ ] family
is you know has roots in Italy dude they
[ __ ] you know how many flower tight
look at watch the [ __ ] Sopranos eat
here eat some you want something no here
eat this I just told you I wanted it
it's [ __ ] the whole thing is rape you
like it yeah I mean I don't want it but
I like it you raped my mouth with some
[ __ ] yams you rape my mouth with some
[ __ ] yams
that's how being Italian is you want
something you want something to eat
every time I go over my mom you want
something to eat no just tuna salad in
the fridge
no here 15 minutes later what oh there's
the sandwich okay and I'm eating it I
didn't want it eat put it in your mouth
put it in your mouth true it is
swallowed eat the whole damn thing
eat the whole thing I don't want to
you're gonna eat the whole thing I don't
want to you're gonna do it I'm not gonna
be I'm gonna be the [ __ ] out of you oh
okay you like you you're gonna eat it
and then okay
I'm gonna [ __ ] tell everybody you're
doing this you're gonna keep your mouth
shut
no I'm gonna tell people you're gonna
keep your mouth to shut that you're
gonna eat the tuna salad you're gonna
keep your mouth shut
no I'm gonna tell people you can tell
whoever you want they know they're not
gonna believe you they think they're
gonna believe it your word against mine
I'm a successful a businessman you're
gonna eat the pasta you're gonna go out
there you're gonna tell people they're
not gonna believe a word do you say I
was at his house and he [ __ ] made me
eat a bunch of pasta do it I didn't like
it he asked
the pasta she asked for the plate of a
pasta and he showed up with a fork and
knife he was a dressed for the occasion
and hated that's the dumbest bit I've
ever done
I'm pretty sure I could have been
canceled for that for sure a year and a
half ago anyway
times change in comedy changes Oh long
as you say the right thing a [ __ ] year
later it's okay our before after the
[ __ ] hot zone before or after the
[ __ ] hot zone of the [ __ ] problem
at during the time Brown but in [ __ ]
five years or about a year ago it was
perfectly fine hiiiiii but now you got
Stanley Tucci on that [ __ ] black and
white video saying I won't make even
jokes about black people you have my
word what was that video I had friends
in that video they got wound but the
gram real friends in that video brown
it's weird when it's close to home Brown
the [ __ ] imagine song was one thing
because I didn't know anyone in the
video brown so I called up stupid Brown
but this new one I got friends in it and
I don't know what to say about a brown
because you know men eat the pasta and
the shuttered your mouth you leave at
the place and nobody gonna believe you
so I'm [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] dude
I mean sweaty and [ __ ] sexy dude
there's so much [ __ ] that happened do it
what is this [ __ ] dude one fire just
sent me a look we've never talking about
the right wedding DJ boobs slap like
what No
[Music]
how about these oh wait okay I've seen
this this has to be fake dude I
understand he does it what the [ __ ] is
this dude this guy wedding singer boobs
slap dude
unbelievable it has half a million views
this guy is a DJ that's just killing it
at this place and you can tell because
he's a [ __ ] pasty white guy and
nobody kills [ __ ] DJing at [ __ ]
corporate events or also weddings or bar
mitzvahs than a [ __ ] pasty white
blonde dude with blonde hair that is
[ __ ] also his hips are wider than the
shoulders and that's what this guy is
and there is a girl on the other side of
the [ __ ] podium after his I guess I
gotta go and we got a ladder looking
yeah everyone's [ __ ] lying around and
then [ __ ] he takes a break from that
turns to the lady and just [ __ ]
straight up slaps her titties dude he
just goes damn bang bang bang bang with
no respect for a [ __ ] female form and
that guy I guarantee you if this guy is
doing that which is 100% exactly what he
wants
living like that I guarantee you he will
live to be over 100 years old because
that's the key to life dude if you do
what you want when you want it and this
guy is not only doing what he wants
slapping titties he's doing it when he
wants it because he's doing it not only
while tens of maybe a hundred people are
looking at him he's doing it on the job
this dude is the truest gangster I've
ever seen this pasty white dude shaped
like a pear with blonde [ __ ] thinning
hair and a bowtie
straight-up took a break from his job
and instead of going to the watercooler
said hey check it out
I'm gonna [ __ ] meet slap some titties
he just goes thanks dude with the
disrespect - he [ __ ] kicked his elbow
out and did it like it wasn't like a
[ __ ] pat pat like a tight petpak slap
like where he was like getting ready for
some pep PAP he just goes like this Pat
like like swings his elbow out it was a
lazy slap dude this dude is going to
live mark my [ __ ] words - he could
eat all the [ __ ] processed meat he
could smoke he can do coke this dude is
gonna live past a hundred and this is
where we all need to get we don't need
to [ __ ] actually he's probably not
assaulting because probably is like his
wife hopefully Matt if it's just a
random stranger dude disc I'm gonna slap
her you titty should nobody's gonna
believe you it's gonna be our video it
doesn't matter
unreal dude she just stands there - Wow
amazing
also how about just straight up in any
case the least sexy thing you can
possibly do like I'm talking about
eating a [ __ ] turkey leg while
[ __ ] is more sexy than just batting
this [ __ ] at some titties like it's a
pinata
[Laughter]
alright dude I'm out you guys are great
thank you very much for listening
wow thanks for sending me that video
won't fire what a good job you know what
one higher so you guys are cool
and watch my special no pain
and what else dude you can text me that
[ __ ] that numbers on my Instagram
and I don't know what else is going on
in the world but hopefully next week
there'll be a world to come back to you
know shit's getting worse and worse by
the day all good and you know have a
good one guys
thank you
[Music]
the hierarchy of guys [ __ ]